i was in england and i got a chance to
talk to you and i was telling you how
much i like your show afterlife i really
do
uh like the series and we've got a new
season now and we talked about at the
time
the show is i really love it it's also
it's dark
and it's clear that you are thinking a
lot about your own mortality
all the time and it's it influences your
work
do you think about it do you think about
how you want to go
i think that um i think i'm drawn to it
and i think comedians are obsessed with
it because it's the last taboo and it
makes
people feel uncomfortable and i like
taking people
to the dark place and you know it's like
taking them through a scary forest and
out the other side i think that
no harm can come from discussing taboo
subjects and i think
we find that funny we find being scared
funny and um and and death obviously is
the ultimate but
uh i don't i don't think i think more of
it
more when i die i think um i'm resigned
to it
you know we're all going to die there's
nothing i can do about it
so the best thing is to enjoy life as
much as you can and um
i don't really i don't really care about
i don't care about being dead
because i won't know about it that is
that is the best thing about being dead
it's right you're not like being stupid
it's only painful for others
yeah um but i suppose i worry about how
i die i don't want to die
you know alone or in agony or and i
don't want to die an embarrassing death
you know what i mean i think about that
a lot i don't want to be embarrassed or
humiliated in any way
i you know i i don't want that i don't
want that i want it to be a very
dignified death
exactly like um there was a there was a
uh years ago there was a british mp
that was found hung
in his wardrobe right wearing ladies
tights
with an orange laced with ammo nitrate
i mean it was masturbating let's be
honest
there's no doubt about that so i mean i
would you know we wouldn't want to be
fat
if i am found i'm not into that stuff so
if i am found like that
right one of my friends has stitched me
up they've dressed me up after my death
and called the papers i just want to say
that now right
could you have you got a ward i bet you
haven't got a wardrobe big enough for
you to hang yourself while masturbating
have you
no i don't have a very small closet i've
actually tested it to see could i hang
myself in here
while masturbating and i've i've i had
carpenters come in
and they were saying no no no you don't
have enough room for that
you know because masturbating you need
elbow room and i would love to see
shopping that would be great and go
could i speak to the manager what is it
[Laughter]
what's your what's your biggest what's
your roomiest wardrobe
yeah and i'll be honest with the guy
i'll say look
i need to hang myself while masturbating
and there's no
here for that plus you still need room
for the clothes
and so yeah we're talking about here
yeah
and you don't need to be too suspicious
you don't want people to walk into your
bedroom and go
is that a death wanking wardrobe so you
want to
look like a normal wardrobe and then
when you go inside there's like
you know things like steps and like a
really
good bar a really good weight
[Laughter]
now are you you want to be do you want
to be buried cremated have you thought
about that
do you want what do you want to happen
with your body once you're gone
don't care i thought it'd be good to be
um
just fed to the lions at london zoo
that'd be useful isn't it because we
never give anything back we take
everything from this world we just
we animals anything that moves we eat we
destroy we
deforestation club we don't give
anything back everything we do is for us
we're not even food for other things so
i just thought at least then
i'd be giving so i also i like the look
on the tourist faces when they
they just throw this like dead fat
naked 73 year old
maybe if i'm lucky to the lions and as
it lands some people go
is that the blue from the office
what's steve corral no not
[Laughter]
the original office he's much fatter
he's much fatter than steeper steve
caroll's still alive
and looked really handsome and so the
lions the whole time that the tourists
are watching are just ripping you apart
the people are going oh they've never
seen a person being before also
i like the idea that the lion they
always start with the soft bits
but if two lions went for my testicles
right they'd be in for a shot because
they're really gristly
and long so you'd have two lines like
about three feet apart
it'd be like lady in the [ __ ] they're
eating my testicles getting close
together
then they meet in the middle and kiss
yeah and they fall in love
and all the tourists go
[Laughter]